[Music]
whoa what is this place
Playhouse what's not doing here
in dreams our minds sometimes try to
find ways of coping with the things that
we can't quite process when we're awake
the things that are too sad or too scary
or just too big for us to understand
among the sleep uses the fertile ground
of a child sleeping psyche as its
setting conjuring surreal landscapes
that views the familiar and the unknown
the game's potent atmosphere makes your
brief journey a worthwhile one even if
in the end the answers you find on your
quest to help a toddler cope with some
painful truths don't add up to quite as
much as you'd hope fact that you play as
a toddler is among the sleeps most
unusual characteristic and also one of
its best this isn't just a first-person
game in which the camera is lower to the
ground than it would be if you were
playing as an adult when you walk your
steps feel unsteady you can get around
more quickly by crawling but walking has
its advantages on foot you can drag
objects around and you can open drawers
which you often need to clamber up onto
in order to reach door knobs or get to
higher areas by making you interact with
the world in this teetering way from
this perspective among the sleep makes
the fact that you play as a toddler not
just a narrative conceit but an integral
part of your experience
here it comes through the tunnel kitchen
after being put to bed on your second
birthday you find yourself in a changed
home your mother missing your only hope
of finding her is to venture through
different realms to find for talismans
that represent memories associated with
her throughout some sections of your
journey
you're hunted by a frightening monster
still your quest isn't challenging
environmental puzzles are never taxing
and it's easy to hide from the monster
who occasional in stalks you though its
presence is still frightening for the
way that it makes the air around you
vibrate and for the staticky outbursts
of distorted sound that emit from it
like screams
[Music]
most of the time among the sleep is a
creepy game rather than an outright
scary one and the sound design is
crucial to the unsettling healing the
game generates knocks on wood
distant shrieks discordant chimes and
other sounds lend a foreboding heir to
the game's strange and imaginative
environments which are quite creepy in
their own right and to be honest it
scares me a bit but don't worry I'll do
my best to keep you safe fittingly these
environments feel like something out of
a dream meshing toys and drawings and
other elements of childhood with
fragments of playgrounds libraries and
other places right with symbolic meaning
the fact that you're playing as a
toddler makes the world around you feel
threatening and unconquered whatever
manifestations of evil might lurk in the
fog that surrounds you you'd be helpless
against them but venturing into the
unknown of each new realm is ultimately
an empowering process even as a child
you are strong enough to face the
terrifying unknown and cope with
whatever you find there unfortunately
the abrupt ending that awaits you at the
conclusion of your journey feels
disconnected from the rest of the game
there's a revelation at the end but it
feels too rushed and too under develop
to leave you feeling much of anything
it's unfortunate that the game doesn't
leverage its intriguing concept to tell
a more memorable story and that its
ending is underwhelming but even if the
destination leaves you wanting the
journey is far from wasted and though
the dreams that conjures might be scary
it ultimately leaves you with the
feeling that you're strong enough to
face your fears in dreams or otherwise
you